así está el semáforo de contagios con
prácticamente toda europa en rojo un
color que se adquiere cuando se
registran más de 50 casos por cada
100.000 habitantes en los últimos 14
días bélgica o república checa son los
más afectados y superan los 1000 casos
por cada 100.000 habitantes también
polonia ha entrado en alerta roja el
mismo día que el presidente android duda
anunció su positivo por kobe 19 alemán
ya que todavía no está en alerta roja
registró récord de casos y ya supera las
10.000 muertes por kobe 19 mientras la
mascarilla se vuelve obligatoria en
berlín pero los protagonistas de la
primera ola de marzo no están en una
mejor situación francia registró una
cifra récord de 45.000 nuevos contagios
en las últimas 24 horas mientras el
presidente macro no busca imponer más
restricciones al tiempo que la población
está bajo un toque de queda esta
enfermedad afecta a todo el mundo hemos
hablado con el personal sanitario de las
medidas que adoptan y una vez más hemos
constatado que la mejor forma de
ayudarles y de aliviar los hospitales es
no caer enfermo y
depende de cada uno de nosotros
el país vecino españa celebra un consejo
de ministros- este domingo para decretar
de nuevo el estado de alarma con el
objetivo de que las comunidades
autónomas puedan aprobar toques de queda
nocturnos también en la península
ibérica' portugal ve como sus unidades
de cuidados intensivos empiezan a estar
al límite todos están cansados todos
quieren abrazar a sus seres queridos
pero se debe mantener las reglas de
seguridad en italia ciudades como romá y
milán ya se encuentran sumidas en un
toque de queda nocturno mientras en
nápoles los ciudadanos protestan contra
las restricciones unas restricciones que
en galés reino unido se han llevado a la
máxima expresión con un confinamiento
domiciliario de 17 días una medida que
podría extenderse las próximas semanas a
toda europa